today on the beddin shapiro show duval
patrick thinks about tossing his hat
into the ring Trump plans his
impeachment strategy and the sports
media therefore political discussions
until they aren't i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show the ben shapiro
show is sponsored by expressvpn protect
your online privacy today like right now
at expressvpn dot-com slash better okay
we've got a ton to get to today there's
a piece in the Atlantic that I really
want to analyze about the possibility of
the country coming apart it's by yoni
Applebaum it's really interesting piece
it's got some points to make but I think
it misses the core points and we'll get
to that in a little bit we will also get
to really Giuliani's new strategy which
involves apparently doing the podcast
um I think Rudy would do an interesting
podcast but not on impeachment and not
well his client is under investigation
and not well he's under investigation
we'll get to all that we begin today
however with some new polling data in
the Democratic presidential race so
according to the Real Clear Politics
polling average Joe Biden continues to
lead in the Democratic presidential
primary race by about seven points he's
about six seven points on Elizabeth
Warren followed by Bernie Sanders in the
national numbers in the Iowa numbers
Warren is up about four points on Budaj
followed by Sanders followed by Biden so
in the RealClearPolitics polling average
Biden has fallen to fourth in Iowa
although his organization has really yet
to make its so make itself felt in New
Hampshire however there's a poll in New
Hampshire that is a little bit more
telling you would expect that in New
Hampshire you would have a run away for
more on in Sanders rhyming they are from
neighboring states
Sanders is from Vermont Elizabeth Warren
is from Massachusetts and yet the latest
poll from New Hampshire has Joe Biden in
the lead in New Hampshire if Joe Biden
wins New Hampshire he wins the
nomination because the fact is at that
point the Democrats have failed to blunt
his momentum and he will move forward in
two states that he's actually leading in
the polls he's leading in Nevada he's
leading in South Carolina he's leading
across the south
so if Joe Biden were to win one of the
first two contests he's pretty much
guaranteed the nomination and this shows
that Elizabeth Warren is not quite as
durable as people are making her out to
be this early on in the race and
remember we still are really early on in
the race guys I mean not a single
primary has been held we're months away
from the first primary being held and
Elizabeth Warren is only starting to
feel now the sort of blowback
bad policy positions and what is in fact
a very rigid and and weak candidacy when
exposed to the light well according to
Quinnipiac the latest Quinnipiac survey
of New Hampshire finds Biden at 20
percent followed by Warren at 16 buta
judge at 15 and Sanders at 14 percent
Buddha judges big hope here is that he
somehow pulls out Iowa and this Spurs
him to victory in New Hampshire and then
he's off to the races
still unlikely that he wins the
nomination at that point if Buddha judge
were to take the first two states there
is a very solid shot that Biden ends up
winning the nomination simply because
Buddha judge has no black support
whatsoever he has not consolidated any
warrants seems to be eating a little bit
into those numbers from Biden but not
enough for her to actually provide the
overall consistent threat that would
Aust him from the race the Quinnipiac
survey of Iowa released last week
similarly found a four cans at a crunch
at the top about three months out from
the first ballots being cast Quinnipiac
poster Tim Molloy said New Hampshire has
mountains Iowa has Plains they couldn't
be more different except for the results
of the last two Quinnipiac University
polls with which both show four
candidates in the top tier although
Biden has a slight lead in the Granite
State it's far from rock-solid and both
states are clearly up for grabs well
this is kind of reminiscent of the
polling data leading up to the 2016
nomination for the Republicans in which
Donald Trump was right near the top in
Iowa but he wasn't at the top in Iowa
and then he was at the top of New
Hampshire but not by some huge amount he
ends up coming in second in Iowa and
then he ends up blowing out the field in
New Hampshire after Marco Rubio's
collapse because the person who actually
AM won Iowa Ted Cruz had no shot in New
Hampshire he could see something similar
happen here with somebody say like Pete
Budi judgment a strong majority of
voters sixty-one percent said they could
still change their minds before election
day 14 percent said they are completely
undecided at the moment among
independents were undeclared voters in
New Hampshire who say they're likely to
vote in the Democratic primary Biden
leads at 16 percent followed by Sanders
and bootie judge at 14 Warren and
Gabbard at 10 percent Biden also leads
among registered Democrats who expect to
vote on primary day with 25 percent
followed by Warren very close to 24%
Buddha judge at 16
Sanders at 14 Sanders says the firmest
most enthusiastic base of support in New
Hampshire 57% of Sanders backers say
their mind is made up and they will
definitely vote for him the next closest
is Biden at 43 percent followed by
Warren at 29 percent and Buddha judge at
24 percent so this thing is is a highly
contested race I mean this is this thing
is
really up for grabs right now Joe Biden
continues to lead in the black vote and
this is a problem for his for his
competitors I mean the fact is that when
you get to the southern states a
majority of the electorate in states
like South Carolina and the Democratic
primaries is black so it's gonna be very
difficult for Elizabeth Warren or Pete
blue judge to win that state if Biden
continues to retain these sorts of
numbers the Washington Post has a piece
about this today it's a state
representative Krystal Simmons one of
two black women elected to the South
Carolina legislature last year and a
supporter of Senator Bernie Sanders has
been perfecting her pitch to the droves
of African Americans who tell her they
love former Vice President Joe Biden
tell me what you liked about Joe Biden
the only rule you can't say is Obama
Simmons tells them they get mad when I
do that but of course that is exactly
why Joe Biden is popular right he was
Obama's VP for two terms you would
assume that they would have some
hangover impact with regards to the
electorate in fact that's his entire
pitch if you were still senator from
Delaware nobody would care he just be
running another quixotic
campaign for the presidency the fact
that he was Obama's VP is effectively
his entire pitch we'll get to more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about how easy it is to rack up that
credit card debt you know you take out
that credit card and you figure ok I'll
be able to pay this thing off and then
you fall just a little bit behind and
suddenly you're getting charged a 20%
per month because the credit card rates
once you actually don't pay them off
pretty exorbitant well it's easy to fall
into debt it is harder to get out of
that debt and this is why you may need
lending club with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
Lending Club is how millions of people
regain control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trips to a bank no high interest credit
cards just head over to Lending Club com
tell them about yourself and how much
you want to borrow pick the terms that
are right for you if you're approved
your loan is automatically deposited
into your bank account in as little as a
few days Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued again
very easy to get into debt while hard to
get out of it which is why you should
consolidate that's it and do the
responsible thing check out my friends
over at Lending Club comm /ban you can
check your rate in minutes borrow up to
40 grand
that is Lending Club comm /ban Lending
Club comm
/ Ben all loans made by webb bank member
FDIC Equal Housing lender go check the
Mount Lending Club com / Ben okay so as
the Washington Post points out the the
Sanders is working frantically to narrow
Biden's commanding lead among South
Carolina's
can Americans who make up just under
two-thirds of the state's Democratic
voters a huge number rather than attack
Biden directly his rivals are mostly
deploying tactics that include Church
visits and tailgate parties holding
private conversations teaming up with
young influencers who can spread the
word Warren Sanders and Budaj edge of
each faced obstacles attracting support
from black voters a challenge that has
been apparent as each has drawn
increasingly large and excited albeit
mostly white crowds to campaign events
Biden has held wide lead in South
Carolina since he entered the race the
beneficiary of wide name recognition
decades of trips to South Carolina and a
stamp of approval earned serving in the
White House under Barack Obama Warren is
trying to appeal to black women it's not
really succeeding Budi judge and Sanders
are aiming a younger activists that's
not really succeeding and that means
that Biden has a commanding lead among
black voters in the Democratic primaries
which is exactly the coalition you need
in order to win the nomination this is
why Barack Obama was the 2008 nominee
and why Hillary Clinton was the 2016
nominee she had much more black support
than did Bernie Sanders who actually won
among white voters in 2016 the problem
is that if you are a top-line
top of the party Democrat and you look
at this field and you're saying hey on
the one hand you got radical Elizabeth
Warren on the other hand you have very
very old Joe Biden he looks old he feels
old he feels like he has not solid he
feels like he is not in command you look
at that feeling you got all this this
field is really really flawed and that
feeling grows when you realize that the
next several weeks are going to be a
referendum on Hunter and Joe Biden
because as the impeachment effort moves
forward against President Trump the
Republicans are going to respond by
pointing out that it wasn't a legitimate
for Trump to ask about hunter Biden
because hunter Biden and Joe Biden may
in fact have been engaged in corruption
and if you're concerned about Ukrainian
corruption then you would want Ukraine
to investigate corruption happening
inside their own country this is why it
doesn't really help that hunter and Joe
have been dragged into the middle of
this for the Democrats 2020 hopes so you
have Joe Biden who's out there saying
that hunter and Joe shouldn't be forced
to testify never a good sign for your
candidacy
when the subject of an impeachment
inquiry wants you to testify you know
this I think has been Donald Trump this
plays right into his hands because this
for him he's trying to distract the
boaters you know what Donald Trump did
was wrong flat-out wrong calling a
foreign leader and asking them you know
and holding back for
ade unless he investigated my husband
and my son you know that is just
flat-out wrong and I think that the
American people say that I think the
people in Congress see that and and
they're gonna stand up to him
okay never a good look for the Biden
campaign and then you look at the other
candidates in the race and they are
similarly not great
we got Elizabeth Warren who continues to
make her pitch basically Bernie Sanders
but nastier and more vicious I mean I'm
not sure how to characterize her talking
about billionaires other than that wait
right here is Elizabeth Warren mocking
billionaires again if you're billionaire
in the United States is not because you
confiscated wealth from anybody else
it's because you involved yourself in an
enormous number of consensual
transactions that better both parties
you know the fact that Elizabeth Warren
has basically made her platform ripping
on rich people when she's worth twelve
million dollars says a lot here's
Elizabeth Warren being a radical maybe
you've heard there are some billionaires
who don't like this yes they've been
interviewed on TV I've noticed lately
two cents out of their bazillion dollars
so here's the thing and they say you
know I worked hard yeah I don't like
anyone else okay this is such nasty
garbage I mean we went through on
yesterday's show at length her wealth
tax proposal which is a complete
unworkable fiasco I mean it's it's a
joke of a proposal it would obviously
have significant impact on the stock
market would force people to liquidate
businesses it would force wealth to flee
the country how do we know this because
everywhere else has been tried this is
exactly what has happened
Warren is is is very off-putting she is
there other Democratic women who are not
as off-putting
Amy Klobuchar not as off-putting soul-g
Gabbard not as off-putting Elizabeth
Warren is a very often though she was
off-putting when she was in Harvard Law
School this idea that it is sexist to
point out that she's personally sort of
off-putting sorry that's the way it is
and that ain't sexist there are plenty
of males who are off-putting as well we
can name them yeah there are many in the
2016 Republican primaries who are very
off-putting chris Christie is an
off-putting human being there are lots
of off-putting human beings elizabeth
warren happens to number among them the
way she's fighting it back against that
accusation is saying that if you even
question whether she is the kindest
generous
most wonderful person the person you'd
want to have a beer with which just
sounds awful then this means you're a
sexist she put out a statement yesterday
saying over and over we are told that
women are not allowed to be angry it
makes us unattractive to powerful men
who want us to be quiet no you're
allowed to be angry but we're also
allowed to react to your anger by saying
lady we have a 3.6 percent unemployment
rate you're worth 12 million dollars
you came according your own story from
nothing what exactly whining about she
says it's not just women when we speak
up against Wall Street and big tech when
we make our voices heard against
injustice and greed we are told everyone
who has less power should be quiet now
you can talk as much as you want in fact
continue talking Elizabeth Warren I
would prefer that she continue talking
as this fight isn't really about anger
or emotion or civility it's about power
those who have it and those who don't
plan to let it go
she's a harvard law professor living in
the lap of luxury worth twelve million
dollars receiving endless endless
accolades from a drooling media but
don't worry she is not powerful she's
not powerful she's one of you she's one
of the people she says well I am angry
and I own it it's just so tiresome it is
supremely tiresome because I'm angry on
behalf of everyone who is hurt by
Trump's government and okay so is that
the candidate Democrats want so you got
Biden who is basically doddering around
like weekend at Bernie's he's
effectively a political corpse being
wheeled around with a giant Obama sign
around his neck and then you've got
Elizabeth Warren who's deeply
off-putting and proposes plans that are
just absurd and insane and then you got
Bernie Sanders he's a full-on kook
Bernie Sanders put out a piece today
called how to fight anti-semitism now I
definitely as an Orthodox Jew you know
someone who has a real stake in fighting
anti-semitism I definitely want to hear
from the guy who is endorsed by Ilhan
Omar and Linda Sarsour
and who has embraced the most radical
left positions it is possible to take on
the State of Israel including the idea
that you should condition American aid
to Israel on Israel giving money to
Hamas an actual terrorist group there's
something he said he said that the
United States should withdraw aid from
Israel and give it instead to the
quote-unquote Gaza Strip which happens
to be run by a terrorist group called
Hamas
I definitely want to hear about
anti-semitism from Bernie Sanders in a
vowed agnostic sloth a theist who has no
relationship to Judaism or really
anything relate
Judaism but he knows how to fight
anti-semitism has this peace in Jewish
currency or which is one of these lefty
Jewish websites and the piece is just an
absurdity
it's an absurdity and this is the this
is the other alternative he says on
October 27th we marked one year since
the worst anti-semitic attack in our
country's history when a white
nationalist walked into the Tree of Life
synagogue in Pittsburgh and murdered 11
people and injured six others
the murderer acted on a twisted belief
that Jews were part of a nefarious plot
to undermine white America a plot to
assist in the invasion of the United
States by a caravan of migrants from
Latin America this vicious lie about an
invasion had been repeated endlessly in
right-wing media on Fox News across the
internet and most disgracefully by the
President of the United States yes
President Donald Trump's own words
helped inspire the worst act of
anti-semitic violence in American
history so now he's blaming Trump for
the tree of life Massacre I wonder who's
responsible for the attempted shooting
of congressional baseball players
congressional Republicans playing
baseball on a softball field who's who's
responsible that Bernie Sanders that
seems like that guy was out quoting you
so if we're gonna play this game then
you got some blood to answer for
yourself I mean if this is the new
standard but don't worry the piece gets
worse he says the threat of
anti-semitism is not some abstract idea
to me it is very personal it destroyed a
large part of my family right like every
other Jew he has family members who were
killed in the Holocaust this is true of
every Jew if this does not grant you
absolute license to hand over your
foreign policy to actual honest-to-god
day to day anti-semites like Delhi Nomar
which is exactly what he's done he says
I'm not someone who spends a lot of time
talking about my personal background
because I believe political leaders
should focus their attention on a vision
and agenda for others rather than
themselves but I also appreciate it's
important to talk about how our
backgrounds have informed our ideas our
principles and our values and then he
talks about how he's a proud Jewish
American which is the first time I've
heard to mention this by the way he
doesn't really talk about it a lot
because again his relationship with
Judaism is strained at best and then he
talked about his father emigrating from
Poland to the United States in 1921 and
he talked about his family being
slaughtered by the Nazis which of course
is true as I say for virtually every Jew
has relatives whose extended family was
slaughtered in Europe and then he gets
to the point he says anti-semitism is
rising in this country according to the
FBI hate crimes against Jews rose by
more than a third in 2017 and accounted
for 58% of all religion based hate
crimes in America
a total of 938 hate crimes were
committed against Jews in 2017 up from
684 in 2016 the New York Police
Department reported in September that
anti-semitic hate crimes in New York
City have risen by more than 63 percent
in 2019 and make up more than half of
all reported hate crimes just last week
on November 4th we learned that federal
authorities had arrested a man in
Colorado they believe was involved in a
plot to bomb one of the state's oldest
synagogues this wave of violence is the
result of a dangerous political ideology
that targets Jews and anyone who does
not fit a narrow vision of whites only
America okay so a couple of things one
he is correct that there are white
supremacist anti-semites I know I mean
earlier this year one of them was
arrested for threatening me and my
family by the FBI so yes I am very very
well aware of these people in fact I
speak about them publicly I'm very very
well aware of white supremacist in their
anti-semitism however to suggest that
that is the only threat to Jews in
America is absurd
he himself cites the New York Police
Department statistics on hate crimes
against Jews rising 63% in 2019 not a
single one of those hate crimes has been
linked to a white supremacist not a
single one the New York City the New
York City police have said that that has
nothing that uptick is happening in
non-white communities demographically
speaking so he is just ignoring a large
portion of anti-semitism in the United
States because it doesn't fit his agenda
because he would prefer to side with you
know actual anti-semites people liking I
know hen Omar and Linda Sarsour both of
them both of whom have endorsed Bernie
Sanders we'll get to more of this
absurdity because Bernie Sanders is a
crazy old kook who just says ridiculous
things and happens to be a damn liar on
this particular issue we'll get some
more of that in one second first you
know how easy it is for people to get a
hold of your personal information well I
am a prominent public figure which means
that lots of people are constantly
searching for my information online I'm
sure there are hackers who are seeking
to get into my email my credit cards and
that is why I use a VPN I use Express at
VPN now you don't have to be a prominent
personality for people to want to hack
your info people want your credit card
info big tech wants to follow you around
make money off your data the government
wants to follow you around keep tabs on
you this is why you should be using a
VPN too and you should be using Express
VPN right now you need to act to protect
yourself from hackers the government big
tech with expressvpn just get it done
you might be thinking security threats
don't affect you personally wrong way of
thinking about it not using expressvpn
it's like you leave your front door
unlocked every night
that's good until it isn't right not
using a VPN it works until it doesn't
one of the easiest ways to secure your
Internet data is with expressvpn you
click one button on your computer or
smartphone and you are now protected so
the only question is why haven't you
gotten expressvpn yet
I mean seriously go protect yourself
visit my special link right now
expressvpn comm slash Ben get an extra
three months of expressive VPN for free
protect your internet today with the VPN
I trust to keep my data safe go to
expressvpn comm slash Ben to get started
ok so to continue with this idiotic
Bernie Sanders piece he says the wave of
violence is the result of a dangerous
political ideology the targets Jews and
anyone who does not fit a narrow vision
of whites only America we have to be
clear that while anti-semitism is of
threat to Jews everywhere it is also a
threat to democratic governance itself
the anti-semites who marched in
Charlottesville don't just hate Jews
they hate the idea of multiracial
democracy they hate the idea of
political equality they hate immigrants
people of color LGBTQ people women and
anyone else who stands in the way of a
whites-only America so watch what the
trick the trick that Sanders is playing
here is he says the anti-semitism is not
unique it is not a unique type of hatred
that spans the political horizon instead
it is just a subset of white supremacist
racism so that's the only type of
anti-semitism they should focus on that
way he can still ally with people of
color who happen to be vicious
anti-semites like Rashida to leave and
Ilhan Omar both of whom endorse Sanders
he says this is the conspiracy theory
that drove the Pittsburgh murder that
Jews are conspiring to bring immigrants
into the country to replace Americans
and it is important to understand that
this is what anti-semitism is a
conspiracy theory that a secretly
powerful minority exercises control over
society that's true what he is saying I
mean like if somebody were to say it's
all about the Benjamins and somebody
were to say that Congress is basically a
Zionist controlled entity and somebody
were to say that Israeli lobbyist
control Congress or that Israel
hypnotizes the world right it might fall
in that category and then they made
endorse Bernie Sanders because those are
all basically paraphrases of Ilhan omar
he says like other forms of bigotry
anti-semitism is used by the right to
divide people from one another and
prevents us from fighting together for a
shared future of equality peace
prosperity and environmental justice
again playing that trick of subsuming
anti-semitism under the rhetoric of
broader anti-discrimination which of
course is a lie you know Tolstoy
famously suggested the beginning of Anna
Karenina
that happy families are all happy in the
same way unhappy families are all
unhappy and
different ways okay well the fact is
that not all racism's are the same
meaning they're all evil they're all
wrong
but they have different components to
them and in treating anti-semitism the
same way you would treat anti black
racism is a category error they're not
the same
they've different people who promote
them not exactly the same thing
he says opposing anti-semitism is a core
value of progressivism which is of
course why he's hanging out with Linda
Sarsour he says it's very troubling to
me that we are also seeing accusations
of anti-semitism used as a cynical
political weapon against progresses aha
so if you mentioned Johann Omar now
you're misusing anti-semitism says
Bernie Sanders one of the most dangerous
things Trump has done is to divide
Americans by using false allegations of
anti-semitism mostly regarding the
us-israel relationship we should be very
clear it is not anti-semitic to
criticise the policies of the Israeli
government okay that's true but it is
anti-semitic to suggest that Israel
hypnotizes the world or to suggest that
boycott divestment and sanctions from
Israel is justified while maintaining
that for example there should not be
sanctions on Iran or Egypt or Jordan or
Venezuela or Turkey which is exactly
what ohon omar has done and then he
suggests that true fight a truly
fighting anti-semitism means standing up
for a palestinian state which is a very
weird very weird move so the idea i
guess here is what then unless you couch
out to actual palestinian terrorists who
are in charge of the come of the gaza
strip and by the way the palestinian
authority literally just like the PA the
PA head mahmoud abbas just paid tribute
to six to a family that had six members
of the family who are terrorists like
two days ago
unless you count out of them you're an
anti-semite according to Bernie Sanders
which is a a weird take so basically the
way to fight anti-semitism is to side
with Hill Hannah Mar Linda Sarsour and
trip into Israel on a dedicated
consistent basis he says that he says my
pride and admiration for Israel lives
alongside my support for Palestinian
freedom and independence I reject the
notion there is any contradiction there
I mean there isn't so long as the
Palestinians were to be led by you know
people who actually care about freedom
and independence as opposed to murdering
Jews wholesale he has yet to find that
leadership
he says the force is fomenting
anti-semitism are the forces arrayed
against oppressed people around the
world including Palestinians the
struggle against anti-semitism is also
the struggle for Palestinian freedom
okay that one your
you're not to show your work there my
goodness the struggle against
anti-semitism is also the struggle for
Palestinian freedom literally if you go
to Israel and you drive on the road to
Hebron hey there is there's their signs
on the road and the signs will show you
a black arrow if you stay on the road
like keep driving straight and then
there's a red arrow if you go off the
side of the road there's a big red sign
since this area is governed by the
Palestinian Authority it is dangerous
and we cannot guarantee your safety
because if you're drivin there with an
Israeli license plate they will pull you
out of your car and there's a good shot
you get killed so is so let me get this
straight
fighting anti-semitism requires what
giving my authority to come us and the
Palestinian Authority that's exactly
what Sandra said so this is the other
Democratic candidate so you got Bernie
Sanders who's a full-on nutjob who was
supported by Ilhan Omar and Linda
Sarsour but says he's fighting
anti-semitism and then you've got Joe
Biden old slow Joe and then you've got
people to judge who is hyper articulate
I mean he's good at what he does the
problem is that when when math slips
he's just as radical as any of these
other cats I mean he will spend his time
ripping on anybody who believes
traditionally in the Bible and suggests
that Pastor Pete is gonna teach all of
us about how to get to heaven by
ignoring large swathes of the old and
new testaments which is exciting stuff
so that that's your field and this is
how you get to deval patrick saying he's
gonna throw his hat in the ring we'll
get to that in just one second first
here is the fact if you run a business
we run a business over here that means
that we have to be on top of every dime
we spend we have to be on top of every
receipt that we have not yet received
and this means that if you run a
business you need to be on top of every
single aspect of your business if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business but there's a problem that
growing businesses routinely have and
that is the hodgepodge of business
systems that you have to navigate and
this is why you need NetSuite by Oracle
it's the business management software
that handles every aspect of your
business and an easy-to-use cloud
platform giving you the visibility and
control you need to grow with NetSuite
you save time money and unneeded
headaches by managing sales finance and
accounting orders and a chart instantly
I mean do it all in one place right from
your desktop or phone which is the
reason that NetSuite is the world's
number one cloud business system again
you need to know everything about
business if you want to be profitable in
a competitive business environment and
this is why you should be using NetSuite
right now NetSuite is offering you
valuable insights with a free guide
seven key strategies to
your profits at NetSuite com slash
Shapiro that's NetSuite comm slash
Shapiro to download your free guide
seven key strategies to grow your
profits
NetSuite comm slash appear oh go check
them out right now okay so in the midst
of all this
Democrats increasingly are going okay
this field stinks and this is why it
Michael Bloomberg said that maybe he's
gonna jump in and now you've got former
Massachusetts governor Deval Patrick
who's apparently considering a
presidential run according to any CN
comm former Massachusetts governor Deval
Patrick is exploring a late run for
president according to people with
knowledge of Patrick's deliberation who
spoke on condition of anonymity because
they were not authorized to discuss the
matter publicly Patrick would need to
decide soon because the deadline for
candidates to get their names on the
ballot is rapidly approaching in some
states including New Hampshire the first
in the nation
Patrick ruled out a run earlier this
year he has since been talking with
Democratic operatives and donors about
launching a campaign
Patrick served as governor of
Massachusetts from 2007 to 2015 he has
not yet made a final decision on whether
to run the New York Times first reported
Patrick's deliberations in December he
said he was not going to run because he
said that it would it would create a
negative process for his family his wife
Diane apparently struggled with her
husband's transition into public life in
2006 though he said last year she had
encouraged him to make the run he would
be competing against Elizabeth Warren
he's very very closely allied with
Barack Obama in fact a few years back
there are a lot of accusations that
Barack Obama was cribbing off of Deval
Patrick's homework because a lot of
Deval Patrick's lines were hijacked by
Obama and then used it very famously
Barack Obama quoted a speech by Duval
Patrick Patrick gave a speech in 2006
for governor in which he did the this
routine about words he said don't tell
me words don't matter I have a dream
just words we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal just words is what Obama said and
Patrick had said the exact same thing
the same year and Barack Obama just
ripped him off just ripped him off and
that was in his in in one of his
speeches I can't remember which one it
was in 2008 he just ripped off to vol
Patrick wholesale he'd done that a few
times and he and he suggested repeatedly
that they had sort of traded rhetoric
with one another so Obama is very close
to Patrick which definitely cuts in
Patrick's favor the problem for vaulter
is that he is not popular on the left
and he is certainly not popular among
moderates so on the left the Huffington
Post has a hit piece on Patrick today by
Zack Carter talking about how he was a
foreclosure mogul the sub headline is
how the 2020 Democratic presidential
contender helped the Republican
billionaire rip off the middle class he
says what makes Patrick a Democrat an
extremely effective messenger for a
fundamentally conservative idea what I
feel we often describe as income
inequalities a shorthand for economic
mobility he once told to think-tank
crowd which sounds fine to me except
that's not what he is saying now Patrick
has plenty of political assets but the
support from Barack Obama is the chief
reason that Patrick is being mentioned
as a top 2020 contender in the
Democratic Party because as the as this
columnist says told from a different
angle Patrick's biography isn't in
uplifting rags-to-riches story but an
ugly tale of corruption among the
American power elite Patrick didn't just
make a lot of money he made a lot of
money helping a Republican billionaire
rap ripoff the black middle class he
talks about this story in 2005 president
george w bush nominated republican party
mega donor roland arnold to serve as
ambassadors in netherlands Arnel his
wife and the companies they controlled
were the biggest contributors to bush
over the previous three years spending
over a million bucks on his second
inauguration ambassadorships are
frequently dispensed to big donors but
Arnall had no diplomatic experience the
appointment looked bad enough that a few
senators including Barack Obama cried
foul but aren't all got help from an
unlikely source Patrick and Erin all got
to know each other in 1996 when Patrick
was helming the Civil Rights Division at
the DOJ Arnold was running long beach
mortgage company which the DOJ was
investigating for racial discrimination
in the subprime lending market the DOJ
and Long Beach eventually reached a four
million dollar settlement when Arnold
came up for ambassadorship Patrick wrote
to the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee to heap praise on Arnold the
billionaire was a good man Patrick wrote
and Arnold's Ameriquest was a good
company
he said that Arnold had stepped forward
after the settlement he said he used the
experience to make a better company
according to Huffington Post this was
not true apparently according to New
York Times business columnist Joe Nocera
the the America West became the world's
largest subprime lender and it was
notorious and apparently Duval Patrick
was making about three hundred sixty
thousand dollars a year working for
America West he joined the company's
board in two
and for lending his credibility as a
former civil rights attorney it's about
the company's operation and the public
image of its founder so expect that to
come up expect the fact that well Duval
Patrick was that the welds of all
Patrick was governor he was involved in
a wide variety of bad activities how he
car the radio host in Boston called
Deval Patrick the worst governor in
Massachusetts history why will he called
out the fact that the New England
compounding center in Framingham
regulated by the Department of Public
Health had done such a terrible job that
64 people died he talked about thousands
of criminal drug cases compromised at
the state crime lab he promised to cut
real estate property taxes then didn't
do it he bungled the Obamacare website
that cost the state seventy million
bucks he increased the state sales tax
by 25 percent he instituted sales taxes
on alcohol which already had an excise
tax so he was taxing the tax the
unemployment rate was higher under Deval
Patrick than it was above the national
it was above the national average
describe the 9/11 terror attacks as
quote a failure of human beings to
understand each other and to learn to
love each other tried to push through a
two billion dollar tax increase the year
before he left office so there's some
serious questions to be asked about
small Patrick how does that shake up the
race however well I mean the fact is if
Duval Patrick seems to be chomping into
Joe Biden's black support in states like
South Carolina Elizabeth Warren probably
becomes the nominee unless he were to
gain so much momentum that he takes the
nomination himself that's a serious a
serious issue for the Democrats as Deval
Patrick possibly jumps into the race
okay in just a second I want to discuss
a fascinating piece in the Atlantic
about the country coming apart because
we can all sense it right we can all
sense this feeling that the country is
starting to fracture in a in a serious
and irreconcilable way and there is an
entire issue in the Atlantic about how
America is coming to power it can we can
we hold together yoni Applebaum has a
piece about it and I think it misses a
couple of key components we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that if you own a gun
that is a major responsibility it's a
major responsibility to own a weapon you
should know how to use it you should be
safe in how you store it obviously and
gun owners know this by and large in the
United States this is why law-abiding
citizens should own a gun to protect
themselves to protect their rights the
rights of self-defense pre-exists
government this is why you should own a
gun well the u.s. ECA believes the same
thing if you want to defend like the
best then listen up because right now my
friends at the U SEC are giving away 19
free chances to a
dollars for the military service gun of
your choice which gun could you get well
here are some hints each one is used by
the brave men and women of America's
fighting forces like the US Marine Corps
Special Forces US Army and more all of
them are known for accuracy reliability
and for being the guns that America's
defenders can defend can depend on you
want to know what they are well simply
text win 287 2 2 2 right now to reveal
these guns and lock in nineteen Freight
chances to win one that's win - 87 - 2 -
it is simple quick 100% free it is
honorable and frankly I think a a sort
of ticket to good citizenship to be a
responsible gun owner make it happen for
yourself right now text win in - 87 - 2
- you'll want to hurry the giveaway ends
Friday November 29th text win - 87 - two
- wim2 8722 + when you work with the US
ECA you get all sorts of other benefits
they've got all sorts of resources
educational resources and Legal Defense
resources all sorts of good stuff over
at the u.s. CCI go check them out right
now text win - 87 - 2 - okay well we're
gonna get to this piece in the Atlantic
in just one second because I think it is
an important piece and has some
interesting points to make but misses
the key the key point as to why the
country is dividing that's that in just
one second but first you have to
subscribe if you're not already a
subscriber you're really missing out
head on over to daily wire.com /
subscribe for as little as 10 bucks a
month you get our articles ad free
access to all of our live broadcasts our
full show library select bonus content
and our exclusive daily where app which
is a pretty great feature if you haven't
checked it out yet if you choose that
new All Access plan you'll get that plus
the legendary left is tears tumblr and
our brand-new ask me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers and special
guests on a weekly basis so stop
depriving yourself this is America come
join the fun / daily wire.com we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so as I say the Atlantic has a big issue
coming out called how to stop a civil
war suffice it to say they don't know
the answer but there is an interesting
piece from yoni Applebaum called how
American how America ends a tectonic
demographic shift is underway as the
subtitle can the country hold together
and it's a fascinating piece because he
basically suggests that the big thing
that is that is driving American
disunity at this point is the
demographic shift the fact that America
is becoming less white is really his
argument he says Trump's apocalyptic
rhetoric matches the tenor of the times
the body politic is more fractious than
at any time in recent memory over the
past 25 years both red and blue areas
have become more deeply hewed with
Democrats clustering in cities and
suburbs and Republicans filling in rural
areas and exurbs
in Congress where the two caucuses once
overlapped ideologically the dividing
aisle has turned into a chasm and then
he talks about how Americans dislike
each other more and more don't want
their friends and family marrying
members of the opposite political party
for example and he says what has caused
such rancor the stresses of a
globalizing post-industrial economy
growing economic inequality the hyper
power of the hyperbolic hyperbolized
force of social media Geographic sorting
the Democratic provocations of the
President himself as an Murder on the
Orient Express every suspect has had a
hand in the crime but the biggest driver
says yoni Applebaum might be demographic
change the United States is undergoing a
transition perhaps no rich and stable
democracy has ever experienced its
historically dominant group is on its
way to becoming a political minority and
its minority groups are asserting their
co-equal rights and interests okay now
here is where Applebaum
starts to miss the point if it were just
about members of minority groups
asserting their co-equal rights and
interests I don't think there'd be a
huge argument here I mean every one of
Goodheart is in favor of things that
ending Jim Crow was a very very good
thing for example nobody wants
discrimination by the government
enshrined in law nobody is in favor of
that nobody likes racism I mean but but
what he is basically saying and this is
where he misses the point as he suggests
that the real reason that all this is
happening is white people are pissed
that non-white people are gonna become
the demographic majority at some points
in the in the next twenty to thirty
years in the United States now as I've
said on the program and elsewhere
I don't care about the skin color of
people in the country I don't I don't
care it whether the majority is white I
don't cover the majority is brown
doesn't make any difference to me I care
about the ideology of the majority I
care about the philosophy of the
individuals who composed the majority I
don't think we got to think of Americans
as various groups of voter blocks black
voter blocks and Hispanic voter blocks I
think that every American is an
individual I thought that was one of the
bases of the Declaration of Independence
and the Constitution of the United
States and yet what the left has done
and this is where they're missing the
point
what the left has done is they've made
exactly this argument that basically the
story of America is a story of a white
majority cramming down its patriarchal
assertions on minority groups and the
story of the last half-century is those
minority groups now fighting back in
effect to to establish their rights
that's not really true that's not really
true the story of America is about
excellent and eternal founding
principles which were not lived up to by
the founders or by generations of
Americans and the gradual imposition of
those principles more and more broadly
over time that means the world part of
the same story but the story that
Applebaum is telling is a different
story he's telling a story where there
is basically a powerful majority that is
now being overthrown by a powerful
minority which is becoming a majority
and so the majorities just gonna have to
get used to becoming a minority well
what happens the idea that we're all
part of one country and that we hold
similar principles that's where the
fusion lies that's what that's the only
thing that's gonna hold together the
country now I'm working on a book right
now all about the disintegration of the
country and one of the things that I
assert is that the only way a country
can last is if the nation believes that
it has a common history and culture and
language and the left has been forcibly
disabusing Americans of this notion
saying that we don't have a common
history right America wasn't founded in
1776 it was founded in 1619 that we
don't have a constitutional culture free
speech is just a tool of the patriarchy
free speech is actually not about each
individual citizen being able to speak
freely it's really about the powerful
cramming down their interest on
everybody else language itself has been
twisted this way we assert that the
rules of linguistic use have to change
because the majority has been using
language to its own advantage using he
and she as biological pronouns is in
fact discrimination
what the left sees is a bunch of white
people who don't like demographic change
it that's not accurate what you're
seeing in the Republic Republican Party
is a reaction to the fact that the left
has decided on two key factors one that
people who come into the country should
not assimilate to American values now
here's the reality people who are coming
into the country are assimilating they
are I mean studies show that they are
learning the language Hispanic
immigrants to the United States are
learning the language just as fast as
other immigrants to the United States
have in the past but there's a giant
welfare system in the United States and
it turns out that new immigrants take
advantage of that welfare system in a
way that all the little grants didn't
because the welfare system didn't exist
in 1900 it does exist now so that means
that the interests have changed a little
bit it is also true it is also true that
the left has basically pushed harder and
faster for infringement of basic rights
so let's say that the right and the left
agreed on basic American rights and this
were just a question of everybody
assimilating into those notions of
rights then demographic change wouldn't
be a problem
the demographic change that a lot of
people on the right seem to be worried
about is really not a demographic change
it's an ideological change there's a
suspicion on the right that people on
the left are specifically looking to
bring people into the country who
actually agree with the left and not
with the right about fundamental
American values and then reshift the
political landscape along those lines
and that's what the right fears and not
without reason because this seems to be
what the left is doing right the left
has not stopped pushing against
fundamental American rights there is a
basic disagreement on the nature of what
America should be and what our founding
values are and whether those founding
values should be overthrown and the
demographic change just plays into that
it just plays into that basic division
if that division didn't exist no one
would care about the demographic change
but the left is suggesting though is if
we change the values of the country if
we try to overthrow the first amendment
in the second Amendment and the Fourth
Amendment the favor met if we try to
overthrow all of those amendments and if
we bring in immigrants who are more
likely to vote with us on all of those
specific issues that the reason that the
right objects to that is because of the
color of those immigrants skin that's
not true the reason that many on the
right are objecting to that is because
the left is seeking to infringe upon
rights that we hold dear and then they
are expanding the
raishin pool in order to make that
happen right that's it that's a question
of ideology that's not a question of
race that's a question of ideology not a
question of race but according to you
only Apple Mamet's question of race this
is why I say that the piece misses the
point he says the biggest driver of this
division might be demographic change the
United States is undergoing a transition
perhaps no rich and stable democracy has
ever experienced its historically
dominant group is on its way to becoming
a political minority yet these
presidents if there are precedents for
such transition they lie here in the US
or white Englishman initially
predominated and the boundaries of the
dominant group have been under
negotiation ever since yet these
precedents are hardly comforting many of
these renegotiations sparked political
conflict or open violence and fewer as
profound as the one now underway okay
but the fact is that those definitions
were expanded the definitions were
expanded why because the definition
itself was not supposed to change the
application of the definition changed
right the rights of Englishmen right
those were expanded to include people
who are not Englishmen people who are
not white people who are not male people
were not property owners right there
expanded the definitions application was
expanded but the definition itself was
not supposed to change what's happening
right now is that the left is changing
the definition of citizenship itself and
then they're suggesting that what the
right actually objects to is the
expansion of the of the application of
the definition that's a completely
different argument and it happens not to
be an honest argument according to
Neapolis is the living memory within the
living memory of most Americans a
majority of the country's residents were
white Christians that is no longer the
case and voters are not insensate to the
change nearly a third of conservators
say they face a lot of discrimination
for their beliefs as do more than half
of white evangelicals well by the way
you can see that happening in he seems
to be suggesting that that is time
erekle that is obviously not true I mean
the fact is that the people who are
leading the institutions of our culture
are people who actively do attempt to
discriminate against Christians there
was a story today about a scientific
some scientific group that has decided
to oust BYU from the science group why
because BYU still holds by traditional
values on sexuality but yoni Applebaum
says more more epochal like EPO chal
than the change that has already
happened is the change yet to come
sometime in the next quarter century or
so depending on immigration rates and
the vagaries of ethnic and racial
identification non-whites will become
majority in the u.s. for some Americans
that change will be cause for
celebration for others it may pass
unnoticed but the transition is already
producing a sharp political backlash
exploited and exacerbated by the
president in 2016 white working-class
voters who said that discrimination
against whites is a serious problem or
who said they felt like strangers in
their own country we're almost twice as
likely to vote for Trump as those who do
not okay that is not because of race
okay that is because of the left's
attempts to rewrite what it means to be
an American and then suggest that if you
objects that you're racist Jonah
Applebaum says in 2002 the political
scientist Roy Teixeira and the
journalist John Judas published a book
the emerging Democratic majority which
argued the demographic changes the
Browning of America along with the
movement of more women professionals and
young people into the Democratic fold
would soon uh sure in a new progressive
era that would relegate Republicans to
permanent minority political status the
book argued somewhat triumphal II but
the new emerging majority was next
durable and inevitable but many
conservatives surveying demographic
trends are concluding that Teixeira
wasn't wrong they can see the GOP
sinking fortunes among younger voters
and feel the culture turning against
them condemning them today for views
that were commonplace only yesterday
they're losing faith they can win
elections in the future with this comes
dark possibilities okay but that's not a
racial point the reason that Republicans
are fearful of losing elections in the
future more so than maybe any time in
recent history is because the
consequences of losing an election may
mean losing your basic freedoms you have
Obama administration State Department
officials writing the he wants to
overthrow Church Stelter wrote this in
the Washington Post that he wants to or
Stangler he wrote in The Washington Post
that he wanted to see the First
Amendment overthrown in favor of hate
speech regulation in the United States
that makes me more fearful than any
number of immigrants of any color
according to the Atlantic the history of
the United States is rich with examples
of once dominant groups adjusting to the
rise of formerly marginalized
populations sometimes gracefully more
more often bitterly and occasionally
violently partisan coalition's in the
u.s. are constantly reshuffling
relighting among new axes once rigid
boundaries of faith ethnicity and class
often prove malleable issues gain
salience or fade into irrelevance
yesterday's rivals become tomorrow's
allies but sometimes that process of
realignment breaks down instead of
reaching out and inviting new allies
into its coalition the
Harden's turning against the democratic
processes it fears will subsume it a
conservatism defined by ideas can hold
its own against progressivism when in
converts to its principles and evolving
with each generation a conservatism
divined by it defined by identity
politics reduces the complex calculus of
politics to a simple arithmetic question
and at some point the numbers no longer
add up now
if the argument here is that Republicans
and conservatives should try appealing
to every demographic group I totally
agree with that obviously totally agree
with that and I think most Republicans
agree with that most Republican most
conservatives agree with this most
conservatives are interested in pushing
forward most conservatives are
interested in pushing forward their case
into minority community like I spoke at
the at the California Republican Party
annual event the the the convention the
CRP convention 2011 maybe and I was
encouraging people in the crowd to learn
in Spanish not because I don't think
that people should speak English but I
think that the language of conservatism
is not relegated to English so everybody
should want to reach into new
demographic communities the problem is
that what the left is playing a trick
and the trick is that if you object to
the rise of the left ideologically and
if you object to the left immigration
policy on the basis that you believe
that the left is attempting to import
people who agree with them rather than
people who are going to agree with basic
constitutional principles that that's a
racial thing it's not a racial thing
it's not an ethnic thing and making it
into a racial and ethnic thing is
actually a pretty strong Democrat pitch
right they they try to say that if you
disagree with the Democrats what you
really disagree with is the racial
movement of the country the Atlantic
says the collapse of the mainstream
Republican Party in the face of trumpism
is at once a product of highly
particular circumstances and a
disturbing echo of other events
according to political scientist Daniels
ablack he says the key variable
distinguishing states that achieve
Democratic stability from those that
fell prey to authoritarian impulses was
not the strength or character of the
political left or if the forces pushing
for greater democratization so much as
the viability of the central right a
strong center a party could wall off
more extreme right-wing movements
shutting out the radicals who attack the
political system itself ok that's true I
do believe that the I don't Lee has to
be center-right I think
that true concern people who are
conservative should wall themselves off
from people who on a wage ethnic war
demographically they should wall
themselves off from the white
supremacist in the white nationalist and
people believe the demographics is
destiny but in order to make that
argument the left is also going to
really have to stop pushing for radical
policies that overthrow rights and then
suggesting that opposition to their
agenda is racism because that drives
people right into the arms of the bad
guys so that this is this is where I say
that the Atlantic misses the point if
you actually want the country to come
back together then it's not just about
the central right standing up against
racism I do that every day here on the
program I make full speeches about it at
Stanford University it's something that
is imperative but it's not just about
that it's about the left stopping its
full-scale quest to break down the
Constitution it's about the left
recognizing that immigration policy
should be to the benefit of all
Americans that people who enter the
United States it's not just about
assimilation that they should believe in
the vision of American values about the
left stopping its full-scale attack on
the Constitution of the United States
and then using immigration as a weapon
in that process that's what that's what
is going on right here and that's what's
creating the kickback that's what's
creating the division a feeling the very
definition of Americanism is being
changed under the noses of the American
people by the left and then you're
accused of being anti-american if you
oppose that change in definition not the
broader application of the definition
the change of the definition itself ok
time for the thing I like and then we'll
get to a thing that I hate so things
that I like today so I was doing some
Jewish reading over the weekend people
frequently write and ask me about good
Jewish books to read because I am
obviously a proponent there's a great
book called rabbi akiva sage of the
Talmud by Barry Holtz it's about
probably the greatest sage cited in the
Talmud Rabbi Akiva who was also a part
of the Bar Kokhba revolt lived through
the destruction of the Second Temple as
well as the Bar Kokhba revolt and then
died horribly at the hands of the Romans
it's a really good exploration into not
only Rabbi Akiva but the the Tom Munich
world and mission a ik world so if
you're interested in Judaism at all you
should go check it out if yours was in
the ancient world that all day actually
should go check it out really
fascinating rabbi keep a sage with it
Hamid by Barry Holtz definitely worth
the read a very easy readin and pretty
pretty good stuff already time for a
thing that I hate
okay so there is a rule in sports media
the rule is that if you are on the left
and you want to talk politics then you
are a hero and if you're not on the left
you want to talk politics you get fired
that is the rule in sports media we've
talked about this my friend clay Travis
who is a lifelong registered Democrat so
far as I'm aware and he fully agrees
that the sports media are
extraordinarily biased to the left like
more so statistically speaking than the
news media actually and so this is how
you end up with these two juxtaposed
stories in the New York Times in
editorial by a guy named Barry pachowski
who's the former deputy editor of
Deadspin Deadspin had turned into this
wild left outlet that had almost nothing
to do the sports right they spent their
days ripping on Ted Cruz until Ted Cruz
who owned them he has a piece called I
was fired from Deadspin for refusing to
stick to sports his two weeks ago I was
fired as Acting editor-in-chief of
Deadspin where I worked since 2009 the
entire staff resigned following me out
the door after we refused a new company
mandate to stick to sports gyms ban
feller installed as the chief executive
of Geo media by the private equity firm
that bought the company seven months ago
called me into his office point to some
offending stories on our home page and
had me escorted from the building this
is the first time I'm speaking about my
firing and my stance remains the same as
in the countless meetings with
management where I explained and
insisted that sports don't end when the
players head back to the locker room we
refused to stick to sports because we
know that sports is everything and
everything is sports it's the NBA how
telling to its Chinese business interest
its pro sports leagues attempting to
become shadow justice systems for
publicity reasons it's the opioid
epidemic rolling NFL locker rooms at
least as hard as anywhere in Appalachia
even as the league refuses to relax its
marijuana policies it's racist fans
chanting chasing black players off the
pitch in Italian soccer matches it's
Washington Nationals catcher Kurt Suzuki
making a make wearing a make America
great again cap at the White House these
last few stories occurred in the past
week and so we're not covered on
Deadspin and stick to sports diktat
forced the outlets with nor the biggest
sports stories in the world
reporting sports with integrity requires
knowing that there's no way to wall off
games from the world outside and this
guy's a hero
putting doesn't matter the Ted spin was
basically bankrupt which is why I
private equity firm had to buy them but
and reinvigorate them and change
everything out but the idea here is that
if you speak about politics from the
left in the sports world then you are a
hero of the Republic
I said this guy petritsky he said
Deadspin was the voice of the
long-suffering fan finding the humor and
the heartbreak and everything in the
world of sports
it was the fan wondering why he was
paying 200 bucks to go to a football
game to watch a team whose owner would
rather pocket profit than paid to
improve the roster it was also the fan
troubled by the culture and politics of
sports the fan who couldn't help
noticing the larger issues of the real
world spilled onto the field okay so and
york times gives that guy not bet right
and and we're all supposed to lament the
the return of Deadspin to pure sport
then there's Don Cherry so Don Cherry is
a longtime hockey analyst for the NFL HL
and he was on Sportsnet and he commented
on Sports Net on on the on the fact that
it was on the fact that it was
Remembrance Day in Canada law on
Remembrance name had been there everyone
wears a red poppy and remembrance of the
Canadian soldiers who fell during World
War one and he was upset because he said
he was walking around the streets of
Toronto and he saw people who he assumed
were immigrants who are not wearing the
red poppy and here's what's on Cherry
said nobody wears a very few people wear
pop poppy the downtown Toronto forget it
downtown Toronto nobody wears the poppy
and I'm not gonna read says wait a
minute how about running it for the
people that buy them now you go to small
cities and you know you know those the
rolls unrolls
you people loved you you they come here
whatever it is you love our way of life
you love our milk and honey at least you
could pay a couple of bucks for poppies
or something like that these guys pay
for your way of life that you enjoy in
Canada these guys paid the the biggest
price okay so he said this and you know
might not be well articulated but he is
entitled to his opinion unless he
happens to be on the on the
anti-immigration right at which point he
gets fired and Don Cherry was indeed
fired from Sports Net Sports Net
president party AB ski absolutely said
quote sports brings people together
eight unites us not divides us following
further discussions with Don Cherry
after Saturday night's broadcast it has
been decided it is the right time for
him to immediately step down during the
broadcast from a divisive remarks that
do not represent our values or what we
stand for okay well I mean you could
just say that right I mean you could
just have that debate theoretically
okay but the point here is that the
media will lament if Deadspin is told
not to do politics but if Don
sherry is told not to do politics then
that is Sportsnet acting as just as a
wonderful diverse company should you've
seen the same thing at ESPN at ESPN they
will cover Colin Kaepernick kneeling for
years on end but if Mike Ditka says
something they don't like because it
happens to be conservative he says
something hasn't like Barack Obama or
something they'll fire him there he's
gone end of Mike Ditka you see none with
Curt Schilling - Curt Schilling can't
appear on the network because Curt
Schilling once tweeted that al Qaeda was
bad and compared al Qaeda to the Nazis
which of course you're not allowed to do
even though al Qaeda is kind of like the
Nazis so just just gonna point out the
double standard in sports media one of
the reasons why sports circulation is
declining the answer to this probably is
to separate off politics from sports
again or if you are going to not
separate off politics from sports then
you should in fact allow the same sort
of freedom of opinion to reign as you
would in the political sphere Don Cherry
wouldn't been fired for saying what he
said on CNN so if politics and sports
are not separate then let a thousand
voices be heard and if politics and
sports are separate
well then supplementing it when
left-wing political hacks start
hijacking sports websites for their own
political agenda already we'll be back
here today with two additional hours of
content I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup
is by Jessica alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
thirty years ago the Berlin Wall fell
destroying Soviet Communism and
vindicating the conservative Reagan
Revolution but that great victory for
freedom created a big problem for the
Libertarians traditionalists and
religious right who made up the post-war
conservative movement what unites us all
now we will examine the rubble of the
Berlin Wall check it out on the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]